we're ready to some cat however reject
nation it's Greg Alba here with the
lovely and talented you could follow her
an Instagram and Twitter at the cat
Alvarado's and her Facebook page can
tell where I wrote comedy cat with a
seat you see a location now see the way
it's supposed to be to spell I thought
II for the C word see for this she work
I saw a cat at flappers ages ago and
she's hilarious you can actually watch a
couple of her stand a bit on YouTube
yeah listen her its not funny there's no
point in her being her I guess who's not
telephony enoki is it really hysterical
and you are you are like don't no no no
blush please make me look good and
almost the viewers think they were
dating always helps Acosta Cassidy did
comedy we're into a challenge video
called try not to laugh shouldn't be the
hardest thing for you since you're a
professional windows business all you
have to do is try it at the lab this
compilation already laughing but if you
fail just start again just keep going
you don't have to go oh my god ohh
laughs that I [ __ ] up this just keeps a
geek out key alright some guy named a
tick the one just oh my god oh my god
word for up or for a show people
[Music]
now no smile it already
[Music]
[Music]
Wow human five years
[Music]
[Music]
she's pretty our enemies are innovative
and resourceful and so were we they
never stop thinking about new ways to
harm our country and our people and
neither do we
at this moment mrs. plays hundreds
waited for tickets to the unveiling of
an eight foot tall bronze statue of a
goat sending Satan I'm just excited to
see my Lord and Savior bath event
represented such glorious Italian stem
I'll do hope his eyes gaze upon me and
then my allegiance is recognized notice
me senpai notice me we have some
questions were crowd here sir tell me uh
do you believe in ghosts no but I know
who to call if there are is that right
yeah and who would that be
Christmas you know very funny okay
[Music]
it's time to kick gum and you can't
that's my ingredients 50 ml fools
the best sweet girl
[Music]
ah how's ah 83 real-estate emergency
after her first age a new material for a
chat I can't believe you've done this
here listen take this and this one is
dead no squealing remember you're a
[Music]
little [ __ ] lovers everywhere as a
message for you from dirt side those are
[ __ ] will appeal to a whole ton ha ha
they made them with lashings of grape
but they've gone easy on the spice
because kids don't like them too spicy
apparently Birds Nathan suggests that
people don't like [ __ ] could enjoy
these ah they live in hope
yeah that could be right I'm real but he
was destroyed Sauron was destroyed I'm
seated please
you are sure with this your daily tasks
Gandalf the game rides to Isengard
seeking my tongue Wow super say you're
saying alright alright well that have
you ever done it turn out the lot
challenge ever watch the video on your
own no because uh I don't think I've
ever had anyone on this channel before
who correct as much as she okay you
totally got me off-guard if I didn't
know we're gonna do that and I was
totally like flowing with you laughing
right on the board and I was like in
that zone of like I mean you were there
guys you're here it's hard to go from so
much laughter this - no black thing that
was not cool you're totally a new person
toll on me I was crazy is outside we
were totally I'm very serious
we were scary you know comedians could
have serious conversations to bring in
the most area yeah as a matter of fact
that we save all the funny for the grout
but the audience yeah you have no actual
jokes outside you're all of this
laughter go home
so hard into a pillow I'm gonna pet my
cat improv yes yes and but also improv
comes from a place truth a lot most
jokes kill sorry are you from California
I am premier Senegal Canadian per second
me yeah well I think it's ready do just
like the second guy who was knocking
over those remembered okay I feel like I
could see some flattery so when I know
that would actually get into a situation
like that yeah I think you're the what
I'm thinking about right now on today's
you it would be David is very walk rain
yeah I can do because just like the
first cone annoying you and then taking
these guys wasn't having a really bad
day or something and what was the free
real estate thing that [ __ ] was
hilarious and I don't remember Bush
saying that thing no way amazing Brad
which was fun stupid which was fun dumb
I mean there was the fake war but I mean
besides that yeah there's a who said oh
only that what was tiny kid government I
think of the guy was cracking up so much
as you know the fact that he found it so
hilarious it was that like genuine
lacquer though no don't sympathize with
his laughter
don't break it I don't like it coming
you yeah yeah broke over five like
everything every other video you were
breaking this is this is a hard
challenge for you that's for damn sure
because then you have I prefer a
comedian in my life who laughs at jokes
I've seen the look on picture you know
those comics you don't laugh at other
people's jokes that's me I'm not gonna
lie I'm not intentionally not as I said
you have a high threshold but I also
love stupid [ __ ]
I know your stupid jokes they're the
best why cuz they're so simple symbol of
heart yes I guess oh this was weird that
guy that guy that you have one of those
right ah tiny short you're like a sexual
experimental person when your swings and
stuff you say you're staying at your
mom's right now and your mom seems to be
would be approving of that based off
what you tell anyway very tackling
process yes n what are we doing man yes
and yeah she would totally approve of a
sex swing now we have a scene for you
guys I looks like he was in pain I can
handle that easily I'm actually a really
flexible back really yeah - oh can you
sell it ah that would involve me
readjusting the whole camera and I don't
want to do that right now he's like put
your leg out here right now
was that a definition to be flexible
right I see that's really good
you just earned yourself some followers
with that one right there a lot of guys
gonna be like that was so hot pretty
like a breeze and my followers right now
are guys of course mm-hmm
if you're a hot girl with a personality
you're going to get followers it's that
simple I have to work for it and this is
the closest like you two were supported
is watching someone else's video there
were suggestions are the tinder one
those no one I like that one cause it's
relatable you open Oh Junior I have you
ever gone on a date with someone here we
totally hate but then right they're hot
so you going yeah yeah yeah it's usually
the girl for the how they're viewing me
they go this guy's hot no personality
but he's not that don't lie but that's
that's the very sincere thing that women
think about me only my looks is what
people
yeah magic tried to look too hard of it
yeah I mean I found cat on mumble and I
swiped right and she she didn't swipe
right for me
which is shocking shocking oh that's why
I contact you saying you want to come
back on the channel because I thought
you're gonna swipe right but you didn't
now we're in this situation
oh no I just got weird if you hear on
the news that I'm missing I was here
transition you subscribe to the real
region click that notification bell hey
cat oh subscribe to a take the 1 of
course cat alvarado followed her at dock
at Alvarado on Twitter and Instagram
check out all her often sexy bikini
photo she has on Instagram I've one
where I'm in a bathtub filled with hot
cheeto so that's hot that's like every
guy's fantasy right there wow that hurt
good burn your crotch a lot of that is
Photoshop oh really
with an actual - you know what is there
like Cheetos like up the year from here
there and then the rest is like a sheet
with a little more Cheetos that we just
like added Oh Hollywood magic guys so
did it burn your vagina off no I was
like shorts mmm it's called an employee
you're ruining the the room photo right
to the camera now